[Música]
salud y bienestar con más romero sal en
directo américa de france 24 mar
seguimos entonces con los resultados de
las presidenciales en francia estamos
dedicándole como ya lo hemos venido
haciendo a lo largo de este programa de
cómo entonces ha quedado francia luego
de esta primera vuelta de la sección de
las elecciones presidenciales esta vez
hablemos de las propuestas de salud de
los candidatos y las posiciones en
materia de salud por supuesto más como
buenos días y antes que nada feliz
cumpleaños en nuestra audiencia también
se está solicitando en este momento yo
como regalo te traigo esta crónica
alrededor de francia que ha sido el tema
del día de la pandemia digamos que ha
puesto sobre la mesa el tema de la salud
ha sido algo de lo bueno que nos queda
de dos años de crisis sanitaria a un
tema que muchas veces queda algo más
eclipsado pero que en este en esta
campaña hemos visto que ha sido no un
punto prioritario pero ha sido bastante
más relevante que en otros años los
electores han estado más atentos los
medios también y por supuesto los
candidatos también a modo de contexto
francia dedica alrededor del 11 por
ciento de su presupuesto de su pib
perdón en el salud una de las cifra más
altas de europa estamos hablando de unos
200.000 millones de euros entonces pues
para saber que en este caso es una
proporción importante de las cuentas del
estado francés repasemos entonces más
respondes los candidatos durante estos
últimos dos años de pandemia además con
el candidato presidente manuel macro a
cargo de la nación por supuesto no mirar
hacia atrás entre nos ayuda a entender
que puede suceder en el futuro y como
bien decías macrón carga con dos años de
gestión de crisis sanitaria que en
términos electorales podríamos decir que
no le ha jugado ni muy a favor pero
tampoco muy en contra en general al
inicio de la crisis tuvo índices de
aprobación altos por su respuesta a la
crisis sanitaria pero luego todo se hizo
algo más controvertido con el pase
vacunal el pase
sanitario también esos cambios las
restricciones que se implementaron y no
en general se ha caracterizado por una
mano firme a favor de las vacunas de
hecho llegó a decir que quería hacer
enfadar a los anti vacunas molestarlos
para obligarlos a parar para que
terminarán sintiéndose obligados a
vacunarse no por el lado del epen en
cambio no la candidata que se opone a
macrón en esta segunda vuelta
ha aprovechado bastante los tropiezos
del presidente para tratar de hacer
sangre y rascar votantes ahí diciendo
por ejemplo que no prioriza suficiente
el trabajo de los personales sanitario
que no da apoyo a los hospitales en
cambio con el tema de las vacunas está
algo más en la cuerda floja que con este
otro argumento que ha funcionado
bastante mejor la mitad de su electorado
o aproximadamente es probar unas pero
hay una parte de la extrema derecha que
forma parte de las protestas anti
vacunas que tanto protagonismo también
han tenido en la actualidad francesa
entonces ha encontrado un punto medio en
general en estar en contra del paso
vacunal pero no declararse en contra de
las vacunas sino decir que está a favor
de la libertad personal pero bueno una
victoria del epen cambiaría radicalmente
en la gestión de la pandemia en francia
y como siempre con todos los políticos
una cosa lo que dicen campañas y otra
cosa es la que hacen también cuando
llegan al poder persona está usted habla
el personal sanitario mal vamos a
enfocarnos en ese punto ahora desde el
personal de los hospitales los centros
médicos como han vivido estos cinco años
de presidencia de macrón pues la verdad
es que en general ha sido una relación
que podríamos caracterizar como algo
turbulenta macrón se ganó a algunos con
el pago de unas primas de 1500 euros
pero en general con las órgano acciones
y los sindicatos sea una relación de
confrontación han habido protestas por
falta de recursos por falta de personal
también exacerbado pues después de dos
años de pandemia y el cansancio que eso
comporta sin embargo estas protestas no
son nuevas vale la pena recordar que en
2017 macrón ganó con la propuesta de
ahorrar 15 mil millones en presupuesto
de salud no de recortar el gasto
sanitario algo que generó protestas
constantes en 2018
también en 2019 y el presidente de hecho
tuvo que reconsiderar esos gastos estos
recortes en los gastos de salud con la
llegada de la pandemia de hecho eso es
algo que también ha sido nuevo de esta
campaña en una día se atreve a decir que
van a recortar en sanidad porque todos
les tenemos muy vivo el recuerdo y pues
todavía estamos experimentando esta
crisis sanitaria entonces a pesar de que
haya cambiado un poco el rumbo de sus
propuestas los trabajadores del sector
de la salud en general no olvidan y
denuncian pues esta falta de recursos y
ahora de cara a estos próximos cinco
años cuáles son las propuestas de macrón
para eso vamos a repasar los programas
electorales de los dos candidatos
empezando por macro no macro han hecho
mucho énfasis en la mención quiere
revisiones gratuitas para todo el mundo
en momentos de edad es clave planes de
detección también ha hecho la promesa de
ampliar el personal sanitario sobre todo
de enfermeros y auxiliares destaca mucho
una propuesta de humanizar los
hospitales que es algo en concreto pero
básicamente es que no tengan que
dedicarse los médicos a actividades como
tan administrativas y por último luchar
contra los desiertos médicos que es un
problema que aqueja francia y es que hay
muchos hay poco personal sanitario en
muchas regiones del país entonces pues
para hacer eso quiere dar más
importancia para médicos enfermeros a la
teleconsulta y también a los
farmacéuticos ya repasamos entonces
estas propuestas del candidato
presidente macrón ahora que dice la
señora marín de penn pues en algunos
puntos tienen puntos en común con macrón
en otros no de hecho la principal
propuesta en salud del epen es prometer
20 mil millones de euros para invertir
más en el sistema sanitario en parte
para cumplir otra promesa que es la de
aumentar el salario del personal médico
también buscan una moratoria en el
cierre de las camas hospitalarias y como
decíamos esta lucha contra los desiertos
médicos en general es una propuesta de
ampliar la social también intentando
conseguir votantes de la izquierda
defensores del estado pero hay una
trampa y es que es desde una perspectiva
nacionalista no dice que la ayuda médica
de estado tiene que ser sólo para las
personas francesas y quiere que las
personas inmigrantes no puedan acceder a
este sistema de salud excepto en caso de
urgencias mar muchísimas gracias como
siempre gracias por ese regalo de
cumpleaños que me dio de esta propuesta
espero que el resto sea mejor claro que
si un cafecito aquí en nuestro momento
ahora luego del programa gracias para un
gran abrazo para ti pasamos ahora a
saludar nuestro segundo invitado el día